-You look great. Thank you
so much for being here.
-Well, you know,
I don't have a life.
[ Laughter ]
So, really,
it boils down to that.
And I'm like six blocks away.
-Yeah.
-So this was great.
-Oh, perfect.
-Yeah.
-You were telling me backstage
you got to visit your mom.
-I did.
She's --
My mom is 103.
-Look at this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Aww.
-And she says
she's not a day over 97.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, wow.
How is she feeling?
How's she feeling?
She feels good.
-She's feeling --
You know, look -- she's 103,
and it's a blessing that...
-Yeah.
-...that we're --
You know,
that many people say that it is,
that I've gotten to spend
this much time with her.
That's tremendous.
You know that.
-Yeah, absolutely.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Great.
-But she's 103.
[ Laughter ]
So sometimes she's here,
sometimes she's there.
[ Laughter ]
And, uh, I'm --
I'm extremely --
She doesn't --
She doesn't have Alzheimer's.
-No.
-No dementia.
-Great.
-She has something
that doctors haven't diagnosed.
She just makes stuff up.
[ Laughter ]
And, you know, it's --
it's interesting, you know?
Many --
You know, you got Branson
and Bezos and Musk
all have spent
billions and billions of dollars
to get out into space, where --
where she's out there
four or five times a day.
[ Laughter ]
And they're -- they're
spending that kind of money.
And I --
I call where she's living,
her assisted living home.
It's a launch pad.
[ Laughter ]
And she's able to --
She's doing this not on --
on pennies really,
'cause she's able to do this --
Her fuel is actually oatmeal.
[ Laughter ]
-They could save --
They could save a lot of money.
-Yeah, exactly.
-It's ridiculous.
-Speaking of family, recently,
I saw you on the episode
of "Finding Your Roots."
-Yes.
-That show. Did you enjoy it?
Did you love it?
-It was extraordinary.
I mean, it's remarkable
to be -- to see your --
There were questions I had
that nobody in the families
seemed to have answer to
or wouldn't talk about with me,
and so it was really --
And you see the pictures,
and then you see, you know,
that they came to Ellis Island,
you see their boat passages --
I mean, it's extraordinary.
It's overwhelming.
-And you found out
that you're related
to Marc Maron.
-Tough relationship, one angry
Jewish comic related to --
Oh!
Another angry Jewish comic.
[ Laughter ]
I was shock--
When he said it to me,
most guys express shock.
I looked at him like,
"Of course.
This isn't news, schmuck!"
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, Roy Wood Jr., who...
-Very funny.
-Very funny and a colleague
on "The Daily Show,"
he -- he's -- his relation
was with John Lewis!
Oh, are you kidding me?!
[ Laughter ]
I get Maron,
he gets a civil-rights icon!
[ Laughter ]
-I know, but it's Maron.
-I mean, I like Marc,
but give me a break.
I want to talk to you
about your stand-up.
The Off the Rails stand-up tour,
right now,
tickets are available
at lewisblack.com.
But this is -- you're one of
my favorite stand-ups.
And then, you went through
500 days of not doing anything.
You were in lockdown.
-Yeah, I was in lockdown.
And here's one thing you learn
in lockdown is
that solitary confinement
is a punishment.
[ Laughter ]
Because your brain can only
go through so many things,
and once it's finished going
through those things a lot,
it comes after you!
[ Laughter ]
-It's true.
-You know, and some people
would do Zoom comedy and stuff.
-You didn't do that?
-No!
[ Laughter ]
That's like a psychiatric test.
You're looking
at a wall of people.
It looks like you're watching
"Hollywood Squares."
[ Laughter ]
I don't need that.
Then they don't -- You have
no relationship with them.
I've got to be in front
of people so I can yell at them!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's exactly right.
Your special -- Your special,
"Thanks for Risking Your Life,"
just got nominated for a Grammy.
Congratulations on that.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This could be your third Grammy,
by the way, for comedy.
-Yeah.
-Did you ever think
you'd be a multiple
Grammy winner?
-No. Who thinks that?
-Yeah.
-You've got to be on egomaniac.
You got to be crazy.
No, I never thought that.
-Never.
-No, I didn't even think
I would be a comic.
I thought I'd be teaching drama
in some
sad little Southern school.
[ Laughter ]
-Really?
-Yeah.
-How did you come up
with the title,
"Thanks for Risking Your Life"?
-Well, we were on tour,
and it was the last day.
Literally,
we were going into a lockdown.
I knew we were going into
a lockdown because my friend,
Kathleen Madigan,
another really great comic...
-Oh, I love Kathleen Madigan!
She's great.
-...and my -- and myself
had been tracking the virus.
Like, we were the Fauci and Birx
of the comedy world.
[ Laughter ]
We knew as much
as could be possible.
So I knew that things
were gonna be happening.
And so, they had already --
Literally, they were getting
ready to lock everything up.
And so, this was --
I knew this was our last show.
And they almost --
We almost didn't do the show.
And I knew that I'd be
going home after this show.
And I thought, "Wow.
You know, all these 1,500 people
in a room..."
-Yeah.
-"...close together."
And I knew what that meant.
And then I said, "Whew!"
I said, "What?"
You know, that thing you say as
a comic, "I really killed them"?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-You know?
Well, you know, what if I did?
-Yeah! Oh, my God.
[ Laughter ]
-So, I was kind of freaked.
-Yeah.
And we had gotten
some extra cameras and stuff
to record what --
'Cause it was really --
I don't think many people
were recording --
It was the last performance
by a comic that was recorded
on that night
before the shutdown.
So I thought, historically --
not that it would win a Grammy
just historically, people would
look at it, go,
"Oh, lookit back there.
Here's a historical document,"
not a Grammy nomination.
-Yeah.
-You don't think that way.
So we did it, and it was --
-And I walked out on stage,
and I looked at these people,
and all I could think was --
and I had no opening line.
As you could tell,
a lot of this stuff
that I'm saying to you,
it sounds like I just
thought of it.
So I walked out, and I went,
"Thanks for risking your life."
And they went nuts.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-It's perfect. And it's --
it was true, actually.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Lewis Black in
"Thanks for Risking your Life."
Take a look at this.
-I'm avoiding getting started
'cause it's hard
to be funny now.
You know -- You know why.
'Cause it's hard to be funny
when everything's
going so great.
[ Laughter, cheers ]
It's just hard to be funny when
everybody's so [bleep] happy.
[ Laughter ]
I travel everywhere,
and, you know, everywhere I go,
I know it seems odd, but they
are smiling ear to [bleep] ear.
It's like everybody's
on ecstasy.
It is like wandering through
a great big Christian camp.
And as a Jew, let me tell you
how [bleep] exhausting that is.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheer and applause ]
-"Thanks for Risking your Life"
is available
on all digital platforms.